[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend in der Not rückt man
zusammen aber verlassen konnte sich
Markus Söder der bayerische
Ministerpräsident auf diesen Reflex beim
CSU-Parteitag nicht so kurz vor der
Landtagswahl ließen Ihnen die
Delegierten allerdings nicht im Stich
trotz bescheidener Umfragewerte Aiwanger
Affäre und erstarrten der AFD wurde der
CSU-Chef mit einem Rekord-Ergebnis im
Amt bestätigt aber reicht diese
Selbstvergewisserung dieser
Vertrauensbeweis unwahrscheinlich denn
sonst würde Markus Söder seine Strategie
nicht zwei Wochen vor der Wahl noch mal
anpassen wie Stefan leifert berichtet
damit ist Markus Söder mit 96,5%
[Applaus]
es ist der Moment in dem Markus Söder
erfährt dass aus der Partei erstmal
keine Gefahr droht Rekord Ergebnis trotz
Rekordtiefstand in den Umfragen ich
danke euch für dieses tolle Ergebnis ist
echt großartig herzlichen Dank wirklich
danke
90 Minuten lang ackert sich Söder durch
eine Rede die die Partei auf den
Endspurt einschwört und die mit
erwartungsmanagement nach unten schon
für den Waldtag vorbaut ich verspreche
euch jetzt heute keine Prozentzahl für
den 8 Oktober fahren nach den
Ereignissen der vergangenen Woche und
ich glaube das versteht jeder was ich
meine es geht auch wahrscheinlich nicht
um einen Schönheitspreis sondern ganz
bewusst man nicht stabile Regierung für
und in Bayern das Umfrage hoch für
eiswanger mischt Bayerns Wahlkampf
mächtig auf so das CSU in der Defensive
die Freien Wähler im Aufwind fordern
schon mehr Ministerien
Koalitionspartner fordert schon von
vornherein das
Landwirtschaftsministerium die CSU wird
das Landwirtschaftsministerium und
Michael er kann überbehalten liebe
Freunde so schaut's aus und noch etwas
ist neu am Wahlkampf Sound der CSU mit
Friedrich Merz an der Seite macht Söder
auf den letzten Metern nun doch die
Migration zum wahlkampthema wir kommen
nicht nach mit dem Bau von Schulen von
Kitas von Wohnungen ist jetzt schon
schwierig deswegen ist es sinnvoll wir
brauchen eine
Integrationsgrenze für Deutschland liebe
Freunde anders lässt sich diese
Herausforderung nicht schaffen die
Bayern Wahl wird spannender als der CSU
lieb ist mit einer Mischung aus
Nervosität und selbstbeschwörung zieht
sie in die letzten zwei Wochen den
letzten
abwarten wir sind gefasst wir wissen
dass wir uns jede Stimme erkämpfen
müssen aber wir tun das ich denke wir
müssen auf uns schauen und wenn die CSU
ihre 40% erreicht was jetzt aus meiner
Sicht das Ziel ist dass wir erreichen
sollten dann ist alles gut und dann
können die Freien Wähler machen was sie
wollen am Rückhalt aus der Partei fehlte
Söder kurz vor der Wahl nicht wie viel
der Vertrauensbeweis von heute wirklich
wert ist wird sich nach dem achten
Oktober zeigen
sie haben es gerade gehört Markus Söder
fordert eine
Integrationsgrenze die ja im Grunde
nichts anderes ist als eine Obergrenze
die Zahl Pi mal Daumen 200.000 der
Vorschlag kommt Ihnen bekannt vor
genauso wie
Rückführung von Straftätern und
abgelehnten Asylbewerbern Abkommen
schließen mit sicheren Herkunftsländern
und so weiter nein wir sind nicht im
Jahr 2015 sondern 2023 aber in den
vergangenen acht Jahren ist nun mal
nicht so viel passiert als dass wir
nicht wieder vor den gleichen Fragen und
den gleichen Herausforderungen stehen
würden die Debatten um Migration und
Asyl im Wahlkampf aber auch der
Überlastung vieler Kommunen geschuldet
sind hitzig wer Ball zugespitzt und
Schuld ist immer das politische
gegenüber aber bei einer Forderung gibt
es nun offenbar tatsächlich Bewegung
Britta Spickermann
ein Funkspruch Stadtgebiet Forst in der
Lausitz im Osten Deutschlands
Grenzgebiet zu Polen und Tschechien
auffälliger Transporter mit polnischen
Kennzeichen der Bundespolizist macht
eine Entdeckung die fast schon zum
Alltag gehört Flüchtlinge
zusammengefährt die Bilder erinnern an
die flüchtlingskrise 2015
Kanzler Scholz heute in Hessen im
Wahlkampf für Nancy Felser versuchter
Rückenwind doch der Wind bläst ihr
entgegen Nein zu stationären
Grenzkontrollen das war ihre Linie jetzt
die Kehrtwende in Hessen jedoch bleibt
sie allgemein
ja wir müssen die irreguläre Migration
begrenzen die Schlagzeilen sind
deutlicher Faser für Grenzkontrollen zu
Polen und Tschechien solche zusätzlichen
Kontrollen müssen mit der Überwachung
des gesamten Grenzgebiets durch die
Schleierfahndung gut zusammengreifen
Olaf Scholz nennt Grenzkontrolle
Beispiele
darum haben wir besondere
Schutzmaßnahmen an der Grenze zu
Österreich darum hat die Innenministerin
eine Vereinbarung abgeschlossen mit der
Schweiz die ganz gut funktioniert darum
gucken wir ob wir sowas mit Tschechien
hinbekommen können es bewegt sich etwas
die Union verbuchtes für sich der
CDU-Vorsitzende zu Gast beim
CSU-Parteitag März kritisiert den
Kanzler scharf und bietet Zusammenarbeit
an lassen Sie uns das zusammen machen
und wenn sie es mit dem grünen nicht
hinbekommen dann werfen Sie sie raus
dann machen wir es mit ihnen aber wir
müssen dieses Problem lösen liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde ich kann nur für
uns als grüne plädieren ein
Maßnahmepaket zu machen zu bündeln
stationäre Grenzkontrollen können ein
Punkt sein wichtig ist dass wir einen
europäischen verteilmechanismus haben
Vizekanzler Harbig sagt seine Partei sei
so pragmatischen Lösungen bereit man
müsste die Realität annehmen der
Koalitionspartner FDP glaubt an eine
gemeinsame Ampel
sylwände auf klare Regelungen wartet die
Bundespolizei in der Lausitz für sie
schon vermehrt Kontrollen durch noch
bewegen sich die Beamten häufig in einer
rechtlichen Kraut Zone
und jetzt schauen wir auf das
aufgekündigte Ukraine getreideabkommen
damit beginnen deine Nachrichten Heinz
Russland geht weiter nicht auf die
Vorschläge von
UN-Generalsekretär gutärisch zur
Wiederbelebung des getreideabkommens mit
der Ukraine ein der russische
Außenminister lavrov nannte die
Vorschläge bei der UN in New York erneut
nicht realistisch guterisch hatte Moskau
Erleichterungen im internationalen
Zahlungsverkehr und für die russische
Schifffahrt in Europa in Aussicht
gestellt die Ukraine hat nach russischen
Angaben wieder die annektierte Halbinsel
Krim attackiert in der Stadt Sebastopol
soll es Explosionen gegeben haben
in der Konfliktregion Berg Karabach hält
die vereinbarte waffende hohe
größtenteils über einen humanitären
Korridor wurden heute Hilfsgüter und
Lebensmittel in die Region mit einer
überwiegend armenisch stämmigen
Bevölkerung gebracht Armeniens
Verbündete Russland meldet pro
armenische Kämpfer hätten begonnen ihre
Waffen abzugeben
auf der Insel Rügen haben laut Polizei
rund 700 Menschen gegen das geplante
lng-terminal demonstriert Aktivisten
gelang es auf das Hafengelände von
Mukran zu kommen und auf Rohre zu
klettern die für eine Pipeline dort
lagern der Bund strebt an dass das
Terminal noch im kommenden Winter in
Betrieb geht
marode Gebäude
vernachlässigte Digitalisierung
Lehrermangel Schulabbrecher fehlende
Kompetenzen schon vor und auch am Ende
der Grundschule und das alles
verschlimmert durch die corona-pandemie
die bildungsmengenliste ist noch lange
nicht fertig aber viele Lehrer und
Eltern sind fertig mit ihren Nerven und
auch mit ihrer Geduld das ist so nicht
weitergehen kann an Deutschland Schulen
ist vielen klar von Bildungsministerin
bis hin zum Grundschulkind und gibt es
aber keinen klaren und beschlossenen
Plan dafür was denn eigentlich zu tun
ist tausende sind daher heute
deutschlandweit auf die Straße gegangen
und haben eine bildungswende jetzt
gefordert insbesondere die die es am
meisten betrifft Stefanie Garage
in der Menge zwei besondere
BeobachterInnen und protestierende
Marlene meis und ihre Freundin Rahel
erdur sie schreiben für eine
Schülerzeitung wollen berichten über die
Proteste heute in Berlin die
Grundschülerinnen fordern aber auch
bessere Bildung ein
das ist vielleicht klein
ere auf dass man mehr Unterricht macht
ich möchte auch Unterricht haben und
nicht nur
zu Hause sitzen oder in die Notbetreuung
gehen
auffallend viele Kinder waren heute
dabei mit auffallend klaren Anliegen
also ich finde es blöd dass sehr viel
Unterricht auffällt weil so viele so
wenig Lehrer sind dass die Politik auch
was dagegen macht dass wir mehr Lehrer
bekommen in allen 16 Bundesländern gab
es Proteste auch hier in Mainz Eltern
Lehrer Schüler Gewerkschaften forderten
eine bildungswende die Organisatoren
sehen die Bundesregierung dabei mit in
der Verantwortung
wir wollen wirklich ein anderes System
in Kita und Schule haben dazu braucht es
mehr Personal wir fordert eine
Ausbildungsoffensive für Lehrkräfte und
ErzieherInnen und auf jeden Fall mehr
Geld ein Sondervermögen von 100
Milliarden Euro und dauerhafte
Finanzierung und ganzgleist der Kanzler
hier in der Verantwortung wirklich Wärme
bundesweite Bildungskrise die auch
bundesweit aktiv zu werden Bildung gehe
jeden an und die Probleme in der Schule
seien die Probleme aller Menschen in
Deutschland die Bildungsmisere zerstöre
ihre Zukunft und die des Landes
weil uns fehlen jetzt schon massenhaft
an Arbeitskräften und es verlassen immer
noch viel zu viele Jugendliche 50.000
jährlich die Schulen ohne Abschluss und
die Menschen verlieren wir können ist
das gesamtgesellschaftlichen riesen
Problem was da auf uns zukommt ganz
vorne laufen an diesem Tag die
schüler-reporterinnen Marlene und Reihe
mit gegen die Krise in Schule und Kitas
aber auch dafür dass jedes Kind die
Bildung bekommt die es braucht
erinnern Sie sich noch an die große
Finanzkrise 2008 in den USA die dann ja
weltweite Folgen hatte so etwas
ähnliches könnte jetzt in China
passieren die Auslandsinvestitionen die
lassen nach der Handel auch zudem gibt
es einen gewaltigen Schuldenberg und und
hier kommt die Parallele zu 2008 eine
massive Immobilienkrise dazu muss man
wissen dass Immobilien in den letzten
Jahren schätzungsweise 25 Prozent des
chinesischen Bib ausgemacht haben also
das Bruttoinlandsprodukts noch ist es so
dass mehr Hausbesitzer ihre Schulden
abbezahlen als dass es zu
Zwangsversteigerung kommt zudem hat Tina
ja auch einen staatliches Finanzsystem
aber Sorgen und Frustration machen sich
dennoch breit Elisabeth Schmidt
in China stehen Makler dieser Tage auf
der Straße mit selbstgebastelten
schildern sie preisen Wohnungen an die
zur Zeit niemand kaufen will sie haben
etwa eine Autostunde von Peking entfernt
Beton in den Himmel 20 Stockwerke hoch
wir fragen nach in einem Maklerbüro
die Wohnungen hätten schon 2020
übergeben werden sollen viele Kunden
haben die Immobilien als Geldanlage
gekauft aber nur zehn Prozent sind heute
bewohnt die Kräne stehen still überall
Bauschutt in China ist es üblich dass
Käufer ihre Wohnungen bereits bezahlen
noch bevor sie gebaut wurden finanziert
über Kredite ihre Wut und Verzweiflung
äußern sie jetzt in den sozialen Medien
wir haben die Ersparnisse von zwei
Generationen in die Wohnung gesteckt
alles umsonst wir können nicht einziehen
aber müssen jeden Monat den Bankkredit
abbezahlen
etwa 100 Millionen unfertige Wohnungen
stehen derzeit in der Volksrepublik
jahrelang wurden immer mehr Immobilien
gekauft die Preise schossen in die Höhe
verdoppelten sich zum Teil doch mit der
Wirtschaftskrise platzte die
Spekulationsblase die käufe sind auf
weniger als die Hälfte des in den
vergangenen Jahren üblichen
zurückgegangen die Bautätigkeit ist
stark ins Stocken geraten der
Immobiliensektor ist für ein Viertel der
chinesischen Wirtschaftsleistung
verantwortlich wie sensibel das Thema
ist erfahren wir als wir mit dem Makler
zur Wohnungsbesichtigung aufbrechen
plötzlich Polizeikontrolle Pässe
vorzeigen Minuten lange Befragung
schließlich dürfen wir fertige Neubauten
besichtigen die Eigentümer wollen sie
eilig verkaufen bevor die Preise weiter
sinken Immobilien als Geldanlage werden
unattraktiver
früher wurden 40 Prozent der Wohnungen
als Geldanlage gekauft heute nur noch
20%, die meisten sind jetzt für den
Eigenbedarf
das Vertrauen in die Baubranche
schwindet China kämpft mit
Wirtschaftskrise und hoher
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit und wird so auch
zum Risiko für die Weltwirtschaft auch
unsere Industrie wird es merken dass in
China nicht mehr so viel eingekauft wird
eine Rezession drohe China derzeit noch
nicht doch die gesamtauswirkungen der
Immobilienkrise sind noch nicht absehbar
für den sozialen Frieden in China und
die Weltwirtschaft
und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags die lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 11 12 17 32 33 39 Superzahl 3
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
die Wetteraussichten für morgen nach
örtlichem früh Nebel teils heiter teils
wolkig Höchstwerte 16 bis 22 Grad die
weiteren Aussichten auch in der neuen
Woche viel Sonne nur wenige harmlose
Wolken und überall trocken wieder wärmer
mit Temperaturen bis 28 Grad
na das ist doch herrliches Wetter um
rauszugehen aber jetzt erstmal noch auf
der Couch bleiben und der Sportstudio
schauen mit Jochen Breyer und dem
sportgeschäftsführer der TSG Hoffenheim
und danach so gegen 0 25 gibt es die
nächste heute Express und uns morgen
hier wieder um 9:45
[Musik]